I set out the progress we as a country
have made against our five tests for
adjusting the lockdown and the measures
we could introduce as a result and today
I want to update you again on those five
tests and set out some further changes a
we can now make so can I have the first
slide please thank you the five tests
are designed as you know to ensure that
any changes to the lockdown are careful
proportionate and safe they combine
analysis of the latest data on the
spread of the disease with assessments
of how well we are placed to meet the
operational challenges posed by the
virus we must do everything in our power
to avoid a second peak of infection that
overwhelms the NHS because that would
lead to more lives lost more families in
mourning and more disruption to our
economy and way of life next slide
please
our first test is to protect the NHS is
ability to cope so that we're confident
we're able to provide sufficient
critical care and specialist treatment
right across the UK and it's thanks to
the efforts of those working in the NHS
that we can still be confident the NHS
can cope on 7th of June 443 people were
admitted to hospital with coronavirus in
England Wales and Northern Ireland down
from 628 two weeks earlier and down from
a peak of 3431 on the 1st of April and
on the 9th of June 492 patients with
coronavirus were in mechanical
ventilation beds in the UK down from 848
two weeks earlier and down from a peak
of 3301 on the 12th of April so that
means we're still meeting the first test
meaning the first test next slide please
our second test is to see a sustained
and consistent fall in the daily death
rates from Kovan 19 so our confident
we've moved beyond the peak and of those
who have tested positive for coronavirus
across all settings I'm sad to say that
40 1128 have now died that's an increase
of 245 fatalities since yesterday as
measured by a seven-day rolling average
the UK daily death rate now stands at
200 down from 300 two weeks ago and down
from a peak of 943 on the 14th of April
so the death rate has continued to fall
and so the second test is still being
met next slide please
our third test is to receive reliable
data from sage showing that the rate of
infection the number of people catching
kovat is decreasing to manageable levels
across the board in total 290,000 143
people have now tested positive for
coronavirus which is an increase of 1003
cases since yesterday the seven-day
rolling average of new positive cases
found through testing is now 1419 down
from 2416 two weeks ago and down from a
peak of 5195 in the first week of May in
a moment Sir Patrick will talk us
through sages latest assessment of the
AR and other evidence on infection rates
based on the various data available the
government is satisfied the third test
is being met next slide please
our fourth test is that we must be
confident that the range of operational
challenges including on testing capacity
and personal protective equipment are in
hand with supply able to meet future
demand
yesterday a hundred and seventy thousand
three hundred and seventy nine tests
were carried out and posted out carried
out all posted out I should say across
the UK are compared to around twelve
thousand at the start of April the total
now stands at six million forty two
thousand six hundred and twenty two
tomorrow the health secretary will
provide an update on how NHS test and
trace is performing on PPE we have
secured over 150 deals with new
suppliers around the world and procured
2.2 billion items of PPE to be
manufactured domestically
despite the immensely frustrating
difficulties we've faced with PPE and
testing in the past this progress means
we are now satisfied that the Fourth
Test is being met of course we remain
vigilant next slide please
our fifth and final test is that we must
be confident that any adjustments to the
current measures will not risk a second
peak of infections that overwhelms the
NHS and I'm grateful to the chief
scientific adviser and the chief medical
officer for their advice on the measures
I'm about to set out and on this basis I
can confirm that the government judges
we have met the fifth test therefore the
government is satisfied that all five
tests are met or still being met and we
can proceed with the following further
adjustments to the lockdown in England a
month ago I set out our roadmap to
recovery and that explained the gradual
steps we would take to ease lockdown as
the data and the evidence allows the
measures it contained
were all conditional and conditional on
continued progress in tackling the virus
we are continuing to follow our roadmap
while adjusting our approach as we need
to as we always said we would although
we are tackling this virus as one United
Kingdom it remains the case that the
devolved administration's are
responsible for lock down in Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland and it's
right that they should move at the right
pace for them according to their
circumstances and so for that reason the
specific measures I'm about to set out
apply in England only first on retail
shops this has been the most challenging
period for shops and high streets in our
history never before of all shops been
ordered to shut in this way it's now
been 82 days since we asked these shops
to close their doors and I know the toll
this has taken which is why I am so
pleased that as the business secretary
confirmed yesterday we can now allow all
shops to reopen from Monday it's vital
that establishments should ensure their
meeting kovat secure guidelines before
they reopen that way we can keep staff
and customers safe while we get retail
going second on social contact I know
how difficult the past months have been
for people cut off from their friends
and family last Monday we relaxed the
rules on meeting outdoors so that groups
of up to six could gather provided they
are socially distant we did so in the
knowledge that transmission of the virus
is much lower outdoors so we could make
this change in a safe way
but there are too many people still too
many people particularly those who live
by themselves who are lonely and
struggling with being unable to see
friends and family so from this weekend
we will allow single adult households
adults living alone or single parents
with children under 18 to
form a support bubble a support bubble
with one other household all those in a
support bubble will be able to act as if
they live in the same household meaning
they can spend time together inside each
other's homes and do not need to stay
two metres apart I wanna stress that
support bubbles must be exclusive
meaning you can't switch the household
you are in a bubble with or connect with
multiple households and if any member of
the support bubble developed symptoms
all members of the bubble will need to
follow the normal advice on household
isolation we're making this change to
support those who are particularly
lonely as a result of lockdown measures
it's a targeted intervention to limit
the most harmful effects of the current
social restrictions
it is emphatically not designed for
people who don't qualify to start
meeting inside other people's homes
because that remains against the law
unfortunately we cannot advise anyone
who is shielding to form a support
bubble at this stage given their
particular vulnerability to the virus
however I want to say I know how hard it
is for those of you who are shielding
and we will say more next week about the
arrangements that will be in place for
you beyond the end of June third on
outdoor attractions because the risk of
transmission is lower outdoors we can
open up some more outdoor attractions
for people to enjoy this summer so from
Monday we will allow outdoor attractions
where people can stay in their cars such
as Safari parks and Drive in cinemas to
open I'm very grateful to the zoo
industry for
cooperation and forbearance and I'm
happy to confirm that they too can
reopen from Monday provided visitor
numbers are managed and safeguards put
in place that includes keeping indoor
areas such as reptile houses closed and
facilitating social distancing finally
we will allow places of worship to open
for individual prayer this weekend and I
hope that will be of some comfort to
those of faith who have been unable to
go to their place of worship as set out
in our roadmap the next set of changes
step 3 will not begin until the fourth
of July at the earliest as the evidence
allows I know that these changes are
only incremental and that some of you
many of you may be hoping and waiting
for more I also know that people will
once again find anomalies or apparent
anomalies in what people can and cannot
do and as I've said before I'm afraid
that is just inevitable when we're only
able to give people a small amount of
the freedoms that they usually enjoy we
will continue to remain cautious and
measure the effect of the changes that
we make and as I've always said we won't
hesitate to apply the brakes if that is
what the situation requires and that has
meant moving slower than we would have
liked in some areas it's because the
rate of infection is not yet quite low
enough and because we're not able to
change our social distancing advice
including smaller class sizes in schools
that we are not proceeding with our
ambition to bring back all primary
pupils at least for some weeks before
the summer holidays instead we're
working with teachers to bring back as
many people's as we can within those
smaller class
sizes we do fully intend to bring back
all children back to school in September
provided the progress we are making
continues so I hope it will that is our
focus and it is consistent that is with
the approach that's been taken by many
other countries in Europe in the
meantime we must stick to our roadmap
I urge everyone to continue to show
restraint and respect the rules which
are designed to keep us all safe and
it's only because of the restraint that
everyone you've all shown so far that
we're able to move gradually out of this
lockdown so please to repeat what you've
heard so many times before stay alert
and maintain social distancing keep
washing your hands help control the
virus by getting tested if you have
symptoms and isolating if you are
contacted by NHS tests and trace then we
all do that
together we'll all save lives and begin
to rebuild our country